with me you know i'm very much about
fairness
and uh it's one of those things that's
very
obviously unfair
hey i'm dave rubin and joining me today
is a rapper an author
and most importantly a british women's
weightlifting champion
zooby welcome to the reuben report how's
it going dave good to be here
it is going well i i am honored to have
a british women's weightlifting champion
here that is you're the first first well
you know not a lot of people can do what
i do so yeah
not a lot of people can do it and for
those who don't know what we're talking
about
let's roll to the videotape
that is pretty incredible ladies and
gentlemen that is
528 pounds
so you did and you identified as a woman
as you were doing that lift i did i did
um
yeah so man what can i say the last six
months the last six months have been
weird
tell me about how that all came to be
okay so
to give people some context on that
video um on the
26th of february 2019 i posted
uh that video on twitter with a caption
just saying i keep hearing about how
biological men and women have no
uh i keep hearing about how biological
men have no strength advantage
over women in 2019 so watch me break the
women's deadlift record
without trying and i wrote at the bottom
ps i identified as a woman while lifting
the weight
so don't be a bigot i put it out there
like i put a lot of content and tweets
out there not necessarily
expecting some sort of huge global
response to it and
the whole the whole thing went nuts the
videos now got about 1.8 million views
it was covered nationally
internationally
on all these different programs all
these different pundits different
podcasts
it it just blew it just blew the gates
wide wide open
at the time that i tweeted that on
twitter i had 15
000 followers and now got about 117
000 as we're recording this so you know
100k
gain largely due to the catalyst
of that video which was weird but it
seems like it touched on
a lot of nerves um i didn't realize how
wide that conversation was happening at
the moment so it seems like it was
it was timed perfectly i did it just
very flippantly without huge
foresight as to what was going to happen
but uh yeah it's good to be known for
what you do i guess
yeah so i i don't want to go too far off
that so you've you have a really
interesting family background and where
you've moved and grew up
and went to college and all those things
yeah we're going to hit all that but
somebody watching this must be thinking
well why would someone
go ahead and do that unless they're a
transphobe
unless they have some sort of irrational
fear of trans people what what point
were you
trying to make there's no irrational
fear of anybody i have no discrimination
towards anybody nor any group
at all um i think people who levy that
accusation are actually trying to get
away from what the actual point of the
video was which was that we have got
this
situation that's happening in a lot a
lot of different countries i mean even
i think it's might affect the actual
olympics as well now where
there's this strange debate taking place
about whether or not
um biological men who identify as women
or who are trans women should be
competing against
biological natural born women in various
sports you've seen this happening
in everything from mma to athletics to
weightlifting
uh to soccer all these all these
different sports and
it's one of those things that's a weird
debate to me because
anyone who's just familiar with basic
biology it's basic biology yeah it's not
it's not about
unfair discrimination or any kind of
hatred or bigotry towards any group or
anything like that it's just simply
saying look there's a
clear distinct physical advantage here
and everyone who
kind of exists in the real world is
aware of that that's why men and women's
sports are
divided to begin with and always have
been
and when you're seeing this happening i
mean in certain sports you've seen
people come out there and crush some of
these women's
yeah well there's all those pictures of
the wrestlers yeah
yeah it's it's uh it's something that
has gone just way too far and i think
the ideological aspect
and the emotional aspect for some people
has sort of just completely taken over
the rational rational and sensible side
of things
because if the if the true issue was
just
having people being able to compete in
various sports
then there are other ways that you could
handle it rather than
that won't affect women's sports in
general so what would you say then with
transgender
athletes well firstly this is
interesting because most people don't
actually know this is that
most men's sports divisions are not
actually men's sports divisions they're
just open
this is something i actually learned
learned quite recently so there's not
actually a rule saying
this is only for men it's just that you
know so whether you're talking about i
think
even things like the nba the nhl the
major league baseball they're not
actually there's no rules saying you
have to be a man
right in the team as opposed to the wnba
which is saying we are the women's
national basketball association
exactly so so you could either to me the
most obvious things would be either you
just have
an open category and anyone who
is not you know anyone
man woman trans woman trans man whatever
anyone can compete
in the men's division as long as they
are within
the limits and boundaries of those when
it comes to performance enhancing drugs
and testosterone levels and things like
that
that would be uh an existing solution
that's already there
or simply if there are enough athletes i
don't know how many
you know transgender male athletes
genuinely
exist at that professional level but if
there were you could also just have
another
another division and that way you
wouldn't be putting women at risk or
making things unfair for them um
and you'd also have anyone who genuinely
just wants to be able to compete and
play
anyone can compete and play so i think
either of those two solutions
would make more sense so the reason why
i say i think it's more ideologically
driven
is because rather than doing that people
do want to shoehorn
it into the existing categories despite
the fact that there is
that there are large biological
differences there is there is an
advantage even if people were to
suppress their testosterone levels
there's still an advantage it would be
like um
maybe a good example would be like a guy
who's using
uh steroids for 10 years and then goes
off of them
they've still got an advantage over a
man who's never used steroids ever
in their life regardless of the sports
right is the ultimate irony of course
that actually by you doing that because
you were just calling out the hypocrisy
and nonsense around this and how it's
activist driven rather than
reality driven let's say that you
actually were taking
what i think would be a true feminist
position
really right you were taking the more
pro-woman
position do you think that's fair to say
yeah i think i think that's fair to say
um
it's weird i think even in the world of
feminism which i'm not
not a part of nor a big fan of and it's
modern-day incarnations
there seems to be this issue seems to be
quite a big split
that seems to be take taking place there
uh
because you've got i guess i don't know
all the terminology but you have the
sort of more gender critical
feminists or the more radical feminists
who are totally opposed
to this and then you have the more
liberal feminists who are saying oh no
well trans women are women so we need to
allow them to come into these spaces
whether those are
changing rooms or bathrooms or sports or
anything like that um
regardless of some of the potential
consequences and it's
actually kind of interesting to watch
from afar and see that split that split
taking place there but with me
you know i'm very much about fairness
and uh kind of it's one of those things
that's very
obviously unfair yeah were you shocked
sort of when when this was catching fire
and you did a whole bunch of podcasts
and
and i think some tv appearances and
things were you shocked the way
you got support from certain quarters
that maybe you didn't think you were
going to get support and probably got
probably if i if i've been through this
once or twice myself got hate from a lot
of quarters that you didn't think you
were going to get hate
or was it obvious to you at that point i
was fairly
it was fairly obvious to me where the
support would come from
and where the minor push back to be to
be honest the pushback was pretty minor
you know in the grand scheme of things
uh when i say minor i mean millions of
people saw that thing
so the minor could still be several
hundred
or even thousands of people but 99.9
of people understood it got that there
was no malice i received tons of
messages actually i mean i do have
followers who are who are trans and
i've got fans who are trans um and they
funnily enough none of them took it as
some kind of
assault or insult already they
understood they understood the point
they understood the humor
um and so i received actually a lot of
messages in support from me from
it was probably a breath of fresh air
for them right because i get emails from
trans people when i discuss
discuss issues like this where people
say yeah that that is the reality i'm
trans but i'm not trying to deny reality
it's an activist driven thing
exactly as you said earlier as opposed
to what
what just regular people want which is
just equality yeah well
i think with most things i think with a
lot of groups that i
see i don't think the activists are very
representative
of the wider population so i don't think
that
trans activists necessarily truly
represent trans people
i don't think that you know lgbt
activists
necessarily represent lgbt people i
don't think that black activists
necessarily generally represent black
people i don't think that
feminism really represents the average
woman you know it represents their own
motives and goals and
ideas and stuff like that but i don't
think it's truly a reflection
of the wider groups and and in most of
these cases nobody appointed them
to have this position or this power
to speak to them but they yell a lot so
that counts right yeah
well this is this is the problem you
know too many people think that just
because someone yells a lot or because
they're loud that they are
the voice of reason or representation
which i think you see this across all
these boards and these
various intersectional groups and it's
not
it's just not true you know you'll have
people claiming to be
black leaders claiming that they speak
for all black people or making it seem
like they do
and you're like you don't you speak for
all black people
all billion billion or so yeah they all
think exactly like me and we
share the same view yeah so i don't i
don't know it's it's weird to me it's
just one of those things i've observed
over the years
and uh yeah it just it
it's just what it is really all right so
now that we've established
that you're a women's deadlift champion
and why you are a women's deadliest
champion
let's back up because your your personal
story is actually really interesting
you were born in britain but you grew up
in saudi arabia that's right about that
yeah so i was born in the uk um when i
was a baby
moved over to the middle east saudi
arabia my parents used to work
over there so i moved here our entire
family moved over there myself i've got
four siblings as well so i went to
school there i went to preschool there
kindergarten
i stayed there i was there kind of all
the time pretty much up until i was
about 11 years old and then i actually
went to the uk for boarding school so
i was still living in saudi arabia but i
was back and forth between the two
countries from the age
of 11 all the way through my
sort of middle school and high school
years if i'm thinking of the u.s
equivalent
yeah and then um also then after i
finished school
i went to oxford university i studied
computer science there for three years
and then it wasn't actually until i was
at the end of after i'd
graduated was when like we kind of fully
moved back
to the uk so and then my family
background is originally
from nigeria so i've kind of got
three different homes in a way and i've
had a lot of exposure to three different
works more than more i've been to 30
something countries in total
but i've had a lot of exposure and
experience in those three different
countries and climates and cultures
which i think has shaped my
own perspective quite a lot and given me
quite a unique view
on a whole bunch of things to be honest
with you can i ask what kind of work
brings a nigerian british family from
britain to saudi arabia my uh my dad's a
medical doctor
and my uh mom used to be a journalist so
so what's it like growing up in saudi
arabia because i think if you just say
saudi arabia people
people just have some kind of image in
their head they can't
really figure out because we've we've
talked about it a little bit yeah that's
right um
so i think it's one of those places
where i guess like like with most
countries depending on
it's it's hard to say i can i can only
talk about my own personal
experience because i think lots of other
people would have grown up there in
different parts and different cities and
may have very different experiences to
my own but my personal experience of it
and my families in general was
mostly very positive um i really enjoyed
growing up there was a great place to go
to school
where i grew up so what were the schools
like were you in a school that was with
people different different international
backgrounds i assume you weren't going
to
a generic school like a public school or
something
in saudi arabia well we were in uh like
an expat community basically so where we
lived was was a little bit of a bubble
um it's actually been weird being here
in los angeles because certain parts of
los angeles look quite a lot
like this yeah yeah i guess we have a
little middle east flair here
well i think because they modeled the
they modeled some of those
they called them camps so they they
modeled some of them after some of the
uh suburbs and areas of various cities
in the u.s
and so in terms of just the way the
roads look
and the way the houses are built and the
trees and the foliage and all that it's
actually really
it's really similar it looks a lot more
like los
angeles than it looks like the uk so
where i lived was to be honest with you
it was a little bit of a bubble so a big
intern like international community um
lots of engineers and doctors and
teachers and because there aren't that
many
like jobs that people really really need
to do there's only certain things that
people go out there to work as um as
expats for
so where i lived was yeah very much its
own bubble but it's very international
so from the age of two i was surrounded
by
people of all you know true true
diversity
um people of all races and colors and
religions and uh
yeah i just i just grew up with that
from the age of preschool i mean i
remember
you can look at my preschool photos and
it's just you got people from everywhere
all these all these different
nationalities different countries lots
of americans
i was in the american school system uh
so i went to boarding school after fifth
grade
basically so i stayed in the american
system up until fifth grade and then i
switched
over to the british system so um
yeah so how is it for the expats like
for example you know everyone when
everyone talks about saudi arabia they
always talk about
that women can't drive which now i guess
is changing a little bit
so like your mom couldn't drive there
she could drive within
the within the area where we lived
wow within the area where we lived so
you kind of have the
the bubble the expat bubble and then
you've also got the real saudis so you'd
experience both so if you wanted to go
out shopping you wanted to go out to the
cities
and stuff like that then you'd then be
in sort of what i call a real saudi
and the rules and regulations are
different so within within the compound
within the smaller community
um yeah women women can drive and there
are less
restrictions on clothing and stuff like
that
things like alcohol and drugs still
still still a huge no-no
yeah but once you get out into the real
saudi then that's where
you know the the regular rules and
regulations sort of
apply so if you're an expat they you
you've got quite a bit of leeway
but you generally you know it's kind of
like when in rome do as the romans do
so if you're going out to town for
example
whether you're a man or a woman you
dress modestly you know people are aware
that
women have to cover up to a degree but
also as a man you wouldn't be able to go
out in a tank top
men don't wear jewelry don't have
visible jewelry showing and stuff like
that
you wouldn't wear like really short
shorts or anything and they have your
arms exposed that kind of thing so that
goes for both men and women
and then if for example if it's ramadan
even if you're not
a muslim or not a saudi native you still
wouldn't go outside
eating or drinking in public just out of
out of respect
for the 99 percent of other people who
are
right fasting so little thing little
things like that and then um
during the day if you're out shopping
all the shops five times a day close
for a prayer so they'll they'll they'll
bring down the
what are they called the shutters
they'll bring you'll hear the prayer
call
you'll hear all the shutters coming down
everything closes if you're doing
shopping you have to you know come
outside and then
wait for 20 minutes uh all the muslim
people
will go to the mosque and they'll do
their prayers and everything they'll
come back reopen their shops in half an
hour
so it's just stuff like that and then
little other things like the
the weekend being thursday and friday
rather than saturday and sunday so
when i go to school and everything you'd
have school from saturday to wednesday
then thursday and friday is the weekend
so i grew up with thursday and friday
being the weekend and i had to when i
came to the uk i was like oh it's
saturday
little differences like that but overall
it was a it was a really good place to
grow up and i'm happy i grew up there um
like i said
it has given me a whole different
perspective saudi is an interesting
place because it's one of those
countries where
very few people have been to but people
tend to have quite strong opinions on
um which is quite rare most countries if
someone hasn't been there they don't
really
think much about it or know much about
it but in saudi i think people always
people are very aware of the sort of
negative aspects
of it but i think there are a lot of
pros to it as well
and it's uh it's just very it's very
different
it's to understand it you kind of have
to come from a whole different
perspective have you been back in some
ways
no i haven't since leaving there i was
last there in 2008
so since leaving there i haven't haven't
been back um i would like to visit
sometimes i do
miss it although i don't really know
many people who are there anymore now
but um yeah my my memories of it
generally are
are very much positive which a lot of
people tend to be surprised by yeah but
um
so then schooling in britain where you
were born
you end up at oxford that we we met in
oxford we did at the uh
at the jordan peterson show yeah my
pleasure
um what what do you study at oxford
computer science
yeah were you going to be a programmer
or something
is that the idea and then he became a
women's deadlift
i'm going to live with that now for the
rest of my life um so
i so i'm really interested in i.t and
technology in general so when i was in
school and i was deciding what degree to
do
i figured that computer science would be
a good
option for me i didn't really love it
i'm not really into coding and
programming but i didn't know that until
i was there and i was doing it and
everything so you know i stuck it
through i got my degree i graduated and
everything in hindsight it's possible i
would have
chosen a different subject just because
after doing it i kind of felt like okay
i now know that
i don't want to go into this field but
um
you know university is where i first
started rapping so i started my music
i used to play piano when i was little i
used to do recitals and concerts and
stuff like that
and then i also played trombone in
school band for two years
but then in my sort of early teen
in pre-teen years i kind of just i
wasn't really into music
which is weird that i've ended up
becoming a professional musician because
i wasn't i wasn't really into music so
much like i did my piano stuff but it
wasn't until i went to boarding school
and i started listening to a lot more a
lot more rap and hip-hop
and i kind of fell in love with it there
but i'd never tried making my own stuff
until i got to university
who was the rapper that kind of caused
the spark for you
that's a good question not a single
person um
i mean my favorite two my two favorite
artists are tec-9
and jay-z i'm also a big fan of tupac
nas eminem
a whole bunch of other people um but
yeah i just started rapping when i was
when i was 18
when i was in my first year of
university one of my friends chris had a
studio
in his dorm room so i used to go in
there and i just
download beats off of the internet and
we'd record stuff
and i got good at it pretty quickly i
mean i released my first album
after i'd been rapping for nine months
wow yeah
so i just put that out there
independently it was a cd called
commercial underground
so i invested like 100 pounds to
make 100 discs and then i just went
around and sold them around my
university and everything like that and
got really positive feedback got some
good reviews and local
papers and music magazines and things
like that
and then uh so that kind of set off the
spark is like oh okay
people are willing to pay for my music
this is something that
could be more than just a hobby so i
started doing it more
started uh gigging around locally and in
a couple other
towns and cities not too not too far
from where i was in oxford
and yeah just started building up my
audience
and then i graduated after i graduated i
took one year out and did my music full
time for one year
and i released my second album the
unknown celebrity and that was when i
just started hitting the streets of the
uk and just going out there with
with my cds and just hustling just going
out to different high streets
different town centers city centers
talking to people telling people who i
am showing them what i'm doing playing
in my music and
you know sold several thousand cds just
traveling around
from the isle of wight to glasgow
swansea north and just all over the uk
yeah yeah yeah just all these different
cities so that's really how i built up
my name
and then um i got a i had a job offer
which i deferred for a year after
graduating
so i moved to london at that point and i
actually worked uh
in the in the city of london for a while
i was a management consultant so i did
the
did the corporate thing for a couple of
years whilst juggling my music on the
side
and then in 2011 november 2011 i took
took the big leap to
go and do my music full time and uh
i'm here today so i haven't i haven't
died yet this is a little bit like a
forest gump adventure you've done like
pretty much like a little bit of
everything that's kind of what it seems
like but let's back up a little bit
to oxford because out of the hundred
plus shows that i did with jordan
the oxford and the cambridge one and a
few others are the ones that really
stick out to me because
i had been in oxford a few months before
and just the the history there the
appreciation for
knowledge and learning and truth and
just
the the architecture and the the little
you talked about a bubble before but
like
the little bubble that is oxford that
you could just sort of feel
that like harry potter magic as you're
walking down these corridors and you
gave me a
nice tour through some of that um
you must have does everyone there really
appreciate
the the level of education that's going
on there i think most people do
and do like did you realize how special
that
that was while you were there yeah
definitely i mean when i was so when i
wasn't still in school when i was doing
uh what we call a levels so the sixth
form
exams that you do prior to going to
university i visited
about five or six different universities
around the uk and when i got to oxford
both the city and the university
did stun me i was like wow i'd never
actually been to the city
prior to then and just yeah seeing the
architecture all the various colleges
and the buildings and
i i really just felt like whoa this is
this is something because it kind of
feels like a almost like a hollywood set
right it does yeah
yeah yeah it's it's a little bit surreal
so that was when i actually decided
in that moment i was like yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna apply to here i'm gonna i'm
gonna see if i can get into oxford
so um i applied to five different
universities
and uh yeah i do remember specifically
actually getting the
getting the acceptance letter i had a
ton of interviews there as well i had
six interviews
yeah how hard is it to get into oxford
it's tough
it's tough most people have two to three
interviews i had
two interviews each at three different
colleges
which was more than anyone else i know
most people have
two three at a push i ended up having
six interviews and
those interviews were were pretty crazy
i mean i remember getting
asked questions like how many how many
sides and vertices does a
four-dimensional cube have
that was one of my interview questions
you're gonna make me do me
here a four-dimensional
yeah so yeah that and then i remember
having to
the interviews are not just um you know
because i was going into
a mathematical and computer science
field
they really want to see how your how
your brain works so they give you
problems to solve it's not just you know
sit down and
tell us about your life or give us in
like a job interview yeah give us an
example of a time you
demonstrated leadership it was it wasn't
like what's your one weakness yeah it
was like
draw us a graph of y equals
and you have to stand up there in front
of three or four um
dawns or tutors right and you're drawing
graphs and
doing maths and stuff like that i feel
like if i were thrown into those
interviews right now i'd be like
at the time you know at the time
obviously i was able to do it
but um yeah so it is it is difficult um
and oxford really i mean that was the
first time
like all arrogance aside i found school
easy
you know i found school easy i nailed
all of my exams i got
the top mark in all my gcses all of my a
levels
i kind of cruised through school pretty
easily
and then the first exam i ever did in
oxford i got 14 percent
i remember specifically i got fourteen
percent first exam i ever so i'd gone
from getting
97 98 100 14 i was like
okay that was that was humbling um so
it's a really interesting place because
everyone is really smart and you're
surrounded by i mean when you're there
you can kind of
forget it because you get used to it
just like you get used to the
architecture and how amazing everything
looks
you do sometimes forget wow i'm really
here with the brains of
not just britain but the world
right because when you're there as an
outsider it's almost hard to believe
that it's still a functioning school
because you kind of
because you kind of feel like you're
walking into the past and you're like oh
people must have learned here 200 years
ago but there's it's not happening now
is it but yeah
it's still happening i think i was at
the oldest college too i think my
college was founded in
12 i would say the 1200s or something
like that
so yeah the amount the amount of history
there and the prestige and everything it
it does
it was cool it was it was cool i mean um
i'm very glad i went there like i said
my particular subject i did i wasn't
super duper crazy and passionate into
but i made wonderful friends there who
i'm still friends with
to this day um and it was really it
really stretched me it really
really pushed me in a way that i'd never
been mentally
pushed before you know just threw me in
there at the deep end
and doing something like computer
science i mean i remember talking to
people
and uh some of the other guys on my
course some of them have been coding
since they were
seven years old i'd never gone i've
never done any coding
when i get there i'll learn how to do it
i was there people who just they do this
in their free time
they've just been doing this for fun
like all the time i've been
going to the gym or running around
outside playing rugby doing all the
various things i do
they were just coding and uh
so in terms of that they had this
you know lots of people that had this
sort of huge advantage over me which
which pushed me over
even harder but um on the other side i
think in terms of some of the
social aspects and other things like
that i think i had an advantage because
uh
it was it was pretty geeky yeah you're a
friendly guy
if you smile what's the uh or what was
while you were there the the political
climate like because when i went there
the first time i spoke at the oxford
union which i i still can't believe that
they asked me to do and it was
absolutely incredible
and i met so many great young students
and and uh hours after
my my talk i was staying around and
chatting with everybody and they
were asking things and one of the things
that i noticed was they were
really really concerned about the way
that social justice is starting to leak
into the academic fields were you
feeling that as someone doing hard
science
computer science were you seeing that
then what years were you there i was
there
to 2004-2007 okay yeah uh
no it wasn't there at all when i was
there which is one of the reasons why
i find what's going on now weird and
quite concerning i think
oxford is still pretty good on not
getting
so sucked into that as i think some of
the universities are i think oxford and
cambridge
have been a little bit of a bulwark
against it from what i can see
but yeah certainly in the years when i
was there not all a lot of the stuff
that is stuff now
out of the conversations that are
conversations now it wasn't
it wasn't a it wasn't a thing um maybe
once in a while you could see very tiny
glimpses of it here and there but i'd
never even if
when i was in university if someone you
even mentioned some of these terms and
words to me
if someone said white privilege if
someone said male privilege if someone
even said identity politics i wouldn't
even know what that meant
i didn't know what identity politics was
until several years
after so a lot of these ideas and
concepts which you're now seeing pushed
both in academia
and in entertainment and in politics and
all these different worlds
maybe it was bubbling under the surface
a little bit
but it wasn't there and also in oxford
they primarily only do the academic
subjects so there aren't
it's quite limited the amount of
subjects that you can study there
so there are some of the social sciences
like for
i don't think they even do sociology in
oxford so
so that kind of insulates it at least
for a little while yeah it does because
the people aren't even studying the
subjects where i think some of this
indoctrination
takes place if you're going to oxford
and you're studying history or one of
the various sciences or
anything like anything like that then
these ideas don't get a chance to be put
into students brains
whereas but they still are getting in
now i mean well they are finding ways
yeah they might they might be now i
don't know what the situation is like
now but
i can i can confirm that when i was
there
lots of these things just were not they
just were not
a thing yeah um like i said which is why
it's it's weird to me when i when i see
what's going on now and i'm kind of like
huh that's
that's new that wasn't you know
10 12 years ago that wasn't a thing that
wasn't something people were saying that
wasn't a
weapon people were using against each
other now you mean you didn't
know that britain was systemically
racist shouldn't you know that
shouldn't that be obvious and no
yeah i i i'm one of those evil people
who doesn't actually believe that
the uk or usa or the western world in
general is as
horrible and evil and racist and bigoted
and homophobic and sexist as
certain people seem to want to think
that it is so this is again where i
think my global perspective
helps me a lot because if people want to
see a patriarchy i mean i i can
i can show yeah yeah i can show people
what a real patriarchy actually
looks like so when someone is in
the uk or in i don't know here in los
angeles and they're talking about the
patriarchy i look at them
with this confused look on my face kind
of what are you what are you even
what are you even talking about here
yeah are you shocked though when you
push back on that from certain quarters
and then
suddenly they almost can erase your
lived experience
even though they're all about the lived
experience yeah
i don't know i people some people get
kind of angry about it
but the thing the thing with me is i've
i'm not someone who's views have changed
a lot over time
i'm not someone who really ever had a
political awakening or i'm not someone
who was
formally on on on one side and and
you know really changed my views or i've
kind of always just been
where i am politically for the most part
how would you describe that actually
i i like to call myself a free thinker
if you had to place me on the political
spectrum i'm
in the center-right libertarian
quadrant of any sort of political
compass test
yeah and as far as i'm aware i've i've
always
been there um but what seems to just
have happened as
we've kind of been saying and i know
you've been saying on your show is that
the world has just
the world has changed you know um
whatever party
you're you're looking at so
i mean last time i was in the states was
just before obama got elected
last time i was in the u.s was september
october 2008
and the democratic party then
even seemed very very different to
what i'm seeing and hearing now i mean
i'm in the uk but of course i see stuff
online i've seen some of the debates and
seen the policies and positions people
are pushing and
again i'm like that's new yeah that's
that's well obama basically ran on none
of the things no i'm pretty sure obama
would be a republican
small steps yeah small steps i mean in
terms of his policies and what he was
saying i mean you can go back and watch
the videos where he's talking about
um immigration policy and the borders
and various issues and you're kind of
like a lot of white supremacy stuff
coming out
he sounds like a republican here yeah um
so it's just
it's just weird how that has changed i
think in the uk as well i mean i don't
watch politics super close on the
nitty-gritty i'm more interested in
the bigger ideas yeah but um you know
even even with the with
the labor party and stuff like that
again it seems to have changed quite a
lot from what i
remember it being 10 years ago or 15
years ago
and things like that so when it comes to
sociopolitical stuff i feel like i've
kind of stayed pretty
still and stable i've become more open
about
what my views and positions are i used
to just kind of keep them to myself and
talk about things privately
and things like that well that was one
of the things that interested me and you
in the first place
however i came across you on twitter and
i could kind of see i've seen this with
a few people
you suddenly see people that are kind of
they're saying something that's
interesting right
and then suddenly you see people start
getting braver and braver with it and
then suddenly
like what you do now where you're just
putting stuff out there and you're
saying this is me
and that's it and it's like that's what
we need more people to do
not just public people we need regular
decent people to be doing that yeah
yeah certainly i mean it just seemed it
was just going so far
that i kind of felt like okay i someone
needs to
the people who are saying the crazy
stuff and stuff that i think long term
could be
quite well is divisive and potentially
damaging to
a wider society they're not going to
shut up
they're they're really loud they're
really vocal online offline and
everything like that
so i and other people who think like me
can't just be complicit in our in our
silence
yeah right i think you said to me you
were a little worried about how that was
gonna
affect the rap career right um initially
a little bit
um i think there's quite a few things
that
sort of protect me in that regard one of
them being the fact that i'm independent
and i always have been
i've made my own career and built
everything i've done on my own terms
i've never been signed to a label or
beholden to
anybody in the music industry or
whatever so i think if
if someone doesn't create you then
they can't destroy you right if they
didn't give you the platform they can't
they can't take it away from you because
i've i've got my own
platform uh probably you're not gonna
fire yourself that's why you're no i
mean certainly not i don't plan to yeah
and then in in terms of even my music
itself it's always been based on
authenticity
and being true to myself and just being
honest and whatnot and not
chasing trends so even in terms of my
fans i mean i had some people be like oh
you're worried about
if you talk about this or that that you
might lose certain fans of your music
and
no i'm not because my fans firstly
lots of them aren't interested in
politics at all so
that's i've got sort of two quite
different audiences so
over the last two years i've kind of
built a more
politically social issue charged
audience
but i've also got my music audience
there's there is an overlap
but some of them are quite different so
the people coming to see me perform at a
show typically they're just there to
because they like the music they like
the songs um and then i don't know if
i'm doing a talk or i'm doing a show or
something like this or an interview
that tends to be more of the people who
might you know
not maybe not follow my music quite as
closely but are interested in
the ideas and like the way that i think
and like the way i articulate myself and
whatnot
so i've just been like you know what
that is that's all zoobee so all i'm
doing is i'm
showing the world a little bit more and
more of me
so you've been getting the music for
over a decade
but now this is what else is going on in
my mind and this is what i think about
this this is what i think about that
there's lots of things that i don't have
a super strong opinion on
and i try not to talk about things where
i haven't thought about my own
idea or researched certain things enough
because i don't want to just
say something for the sake of it and
look silly if i'm going to say something
i quite like being right yeah so if i'm
going to say something i want to be able
to say
and have i've thought about the best
arguments against my own position
and really wait it up and then i'm happy
to
have a conversation about it or put
something out there that people can
challenge me on
and i'm not going to just be like oh
okay i
either buckle or just not know what i'm
talking about and expose myself as
someone who's not too wise right i know
you said that you don't like getting
caught in sort of the nitty-gritty of
politics and neither do i i would much
rather talk about the ideas behind them
but you know we all kind of get lost in
that a little bit
but one of the things i noticed in the
last year as i traveled to all these
countries
was how american politics and the
american
sort of culture war really seems to
reign supreme almost in
every country that you know when i
remember
very specifically when we were in uh
ireland when we were in dublin which i
think was right after i saw you
that it was during the whole brett
kavanaugh
and everyone there was asking me about
it now obviously he has irish heritage
so maybe it had a little more
interest there but i thought this is
crazy i'm in a country across the world
and they're obsessing over one of the
supreme court nominees for the united
states
and that just seemed so crazy to me do
you think that that the us has sort of
exported all of our political kind of
madness to you guys and and throughout
europe
well there's something um like i said
this is my interview with candace owens
there's a
phrase i often use that when the u.s
sneezes the uk catches a cold
and i think that goes beyond just the uk
i mean the the us is a
it's a superpower it's a it's a world
leader in a lot of different
ways people look up to the usa
whether they know it or not i thought
they hate us i thought everyone hates us
and thinks we're stupid and we're bad
and evil
maybe people still like us as far as i
know
even even people who claim to not still
look to the us
well you know whether you're talking
about culture i mean this is where we're
literally where
hollywood is and where the movies are
coming from and you've got the president
of the usa who whoever that person is at
a given time is
probably the most powerful person in the
world and possibly the most famous
person
in the world besides india and china
you've got the biggest
population in the entire world biggest
population by
a country mile in the western world and
it's where a lot of people are trying to
trying to come to where a lot of ideas
and whatnot permeates from whether or
not people are conscious of it
and then with the way the political
climate has been
certainly since probably about 2015 or
so
is it's become i often compare it to wwe
right so it's just
like a lot of people ask me why i don't
talk that much about british politics
and i'm like because it's boring
when i see the stuff that's going on in
the ears i'm just like this is just
it's not just to say you guys don't have
your own problem oh there there are
certainly some problems there but the
the personalities and the stuff that
goes on like
some of it probably is not too um it's
probably it's probably not
good you know in a way the way that it's
become this sort of
form of entertainment and it's like oh
who tweeted what or who said what or
whatever
but is for better or worse it is quite
entertaining
i mean you can't follow trump on twitter
and not occasionally even whether you
like him dislike him ambivalent
i think ambivalence is quite rare but
yeah
it's funny like some of the stuff on
there like when he put the the trump
tower on greenland
and said don't worry i'm not i don't
know you would have been off the grid
well i was off the grid but when i when
i did when i did my comeback show
blane beck presented a few things to me
that he said he said are these true or
false
and one of them was the green land thing
and then this that trump said this thing
about uh bombing the hurricane
and it's like you can't even tell what's
true or false anymore
you know because because even an
off-handed i said to glenn i was like
well the off-handed comment
trump probably did say yeah let's bomb
the hurricane because that sounds right
but it also sounds completely made up
and that is sort of the weird world that
we find ourselves
yeah i mean i think that i think we live
in a time where that's why comedy is so
so important because i think we live in
a time where
for a lot of various reasons people are
losing their sense of humor in a way
and with me you know sometimes someone
will hear me chuckle or laugh at this
oh you shouldn't laugh at that that's
not funny and i'm like no it is funny
it is funny if you have a golden trump
tower on greenland and he's saying look
don't worry i'm not going to do this to
greenland
you know that's fine yeah that's just a
sense of humor and even if you do
find even if someone does find some of
the whole process or situation
frustrating or annoying or what i mean
what better way to deal with something
than just be able to
laugh at it you know when the time comes
to go and vote vote for whoever you
think is
the right person if you like trump go
vote for trump if you don't like trump
go vote for whoever you think is going
to do
a better job if he's as terrible as you
see you're saying he is it shouldn't be
that hard to find somebody
who you think will do a better job but
ultimately
your success or your failure is not
going to have anything to do with the
government
unless you get some sort of huge
tyrannical regime that's really really
cracking down on people's freedoms and
their ability to do things
whether your life is great or your life
sucks normally it's not going to have
anything to do with
the government or politics let alone any
individual politician
so if you're somebody who for the past
two and a half years has been
complaining
about oh trump has ruined the u.s or
trump has ruined my life or
whatever you know i mean i had some
people who you're speaking my language
man yeah finish that thought
bring that because i think that's it
right there if you're saying this guy
and this government
is evil it's not about replace it's not
about just getting your guy in in a more
powerful government it's about perhaps
taking a little bit of that power back
maybe that's the easier way to do it a
better way to do it look i mean everyone
is you're going to succeed you're going
to fail largely off of your own terms
this is the thing this is a blind spot
of a lot of people who
are fortunate enough to have been born
and grow up
in a country like the usa or the uk
especially if they haven't traveled
a lot is that you people do not
understand
just how good they have it even someone
who
by american standards is not up up at
the top
on a global level you still people want
to talk about the one percent you're
still i think
i think to be in the one percent i was i
looked this up i think if you earn over
31 000
a year then in terms of income you're in
the global
the global one percent you're in the
global 1 with an income of 31 000
and then once you factor in opportunity
and
health care and life expectancy and just
opportunity
i mean most people in the world would
bite your hand off
to be living in a
council estate in the uk or in a hood in
the u.s and everyone's still trying to
come here right yeah we're not locking
people in yeah absolutely so this isn't
saying that there are no problems in
these individual countries and
certain cities of course there are um
but i just think that
in 2019 what a lot of people are just
missing is a sense of
gratitude gratitude and perspective i
think are the two things that a lot of
people are missing when you're seeing
everybody just
angry and shouting and complaining and
saying this is horrible and this is
terrible and i'm like what are you
comparing things to
what do you think that says about the
human condition maybe or the way the
internet
the way we can't really understand the
way the internet is changing us
because obviously the internet has done
incredible things and connected us and
you know we met through twitter the evil
twitter right so like there's
all of this incredible stuff people are
watching this on the internet that's all
spectacular and amazing and mind-blowing
from only 20 years ago
and yet on the other hand then it keeps
people in this odd paralysis or this
this state of uh lack of gratitude or
lack of understanding
how good it is in in a lot of these
places in the west
well i think we used to think that the
problem was lack of access to
information and i think that the
internet has proven that that's not the
that's not the issue yeah um but yeah i
just think it's uh
i think it's wow i think it's actually a
lot of things
i think it's a lot of things i think
it's a lack of understanding
of history and knowing how
good stuff is in 2019 compared to prior
decades i mean it wasn't so long ago
that we did really live in you know
there were
virulent amounts of racism and
homophobia and sexism and bigotry and
stuff enshrined in law which says okay
this group can do that this group cannot
do that this people can do that
and and in the west that has basically
been obliterated yeah
and that's yeah and that's and that's
incredible
i mean if you think of the thousand on a
thousand several thousand year
perspective
you know 200 years ago less than 200
years ago people could own slaves
like that existed for thousands that
institution existed for thousands of
years that
on a grand scheme of things you know and
you look at poverty levels and what
people have access to and things like
that i mean a poor person now
or you know relatively poor lives better
than
royalty not so long ago has a higher
life expectancy has better
health care things like that and i think
part of it is
part of the lack of gratitude is people
not understanding that history and then
also not people not having a good global
perspective of how billions of people
around the world
actually live and what they're going
through and what they deal with i mean i
always feel really grateful for example
when i
you know when i do go back to nigeria
and i'm going through certain parts of
the country or you're in certain areas
or certain villages and whatever and
you're just seeing
how people are living and how millions
and
hundreds of millions of people billions
of people are living and whatnot and
you can't go there as someone who lives
in in the uk
or lives in the us and is you know doing
relatively well you can't go there
and not just have a perspective shift of
being like wow like i need to stop
i need to stop complaining about
everything because there
are a lot of people here almost
everybody here would very gladly
swap over with me so whatever i think is
going wrong in the uk or whatever i
think is silly or whatever
yeah good to talk about it but
ultimately
stuff works really well so basically the
people on the right should be funding
they should be crowdfunding
trips really to get like the the truly
privileged
lefties of america to to go to some of
these places and realize
just for i mean it would it wouldn't
take that long no it's not it's not
about it
to see just to see the difference of how
good it is
yeah not a bad idea and then you know so
i think it's that i do also think a
factor is um
the i think lots of the ideologies that
we're talking about now
the goal is to create problems where
they don't
exist really so you'll have
you'll now have people trying to find
you know people are like looking at
every nook
and cranny for they're trying to find
the hidden racism or trying to find the
hidden
sexism and it's like if you have to go
looking for it and start inventing new
concepts
to even find it so for example you'll
hear people say things like
america or the uk oh it's it's just as
racist as it
ever was but it's just different now and
i'm like
that's like that's a stupid statement
that's a stupid statement like
no no one is saying that these things
completely 100
do not exist in anybody's heart or brain
yeah of course they do you get people
who are bigoted but in terms of
the society as as a whole or the the
average person i mean
i don't know how anyone in their right
mind could say that the us is
more racist now than it was a hundred
years ago or 50 years ago or
30 years ago or it's more homophobic i
mean you didn't get hate crammed
as you were walking here in l.a no no
you've been okay out there on the
streets
i'm being dead serious i had some i had
a few people saying that i should be
careful of visiting the u.s now that
trump is president
i mean that said that and i was just
like you really think
that it's like stop watching whatever
whatever you're watching i'm like stop
because no
it's just not it's not true it's it'll
be fine like i'm
you know or it's the people saying yeah
you know if you're
a black guy and you're going to the
states like you know god be careful like
you know don't
don't interact with the cops or this i'm
kind of like man like there's a
starbucks about a mile away from me you
want to go over there and see what
happens
yeah it's yeah it's it's just it's
strange
it is strange but yeah i think lack of
perspective
lack of gratitude whatev whatever
sources those things stem from
those are really what poison people's
brains and i think it's i think it's a
shame because i think that's what's
really disempowering to people as well
i'm very much big on you know personal
responsibility and i do believe that
if you live in a country with great
opportunity
everyone starts at different levels
certainly some people have advantages
and disadvantages of all sorts
so your starting point is not it's not
determined by you
right the the universe god whatever the
situation is
that gives you your your starting point
you don't choose your parents you don't
choose your country of birth your city
of birth
socioeconomic status anything like that
and that's good to understand but
over the course of an entire lifetime
over the course of many decades
i do think that where you end up is for
the most part
up to you it's not up to the system it's
not up to the government
it's not up to any politician or party
you are the person and how sad it would
be if it was right yeah
yeah it is sad so i think most people
sort of inherently know this too
but they still are continually looking
for that thing above them that person or
or if only we can get this guy into
office then all of our problems will be
that person doesn't exist that policy
doesn't exist
that party doesn't exist you can vote
for ones that you think more align with
your
your views and your policies and things
like that but there's nothing that's
going to happen that's going to
fundamentally
turn you from uh someone who's failing
someone who's super successful i mean
that's really a mindset shift that's
something that you've got to take on
yourself it's interesting that you
described it as something above them
because i don't know what your
personal religious beliefs are but i i
know how much jordan peterson has
influenced you and obviously
me as well and that is one of the things
he shifted me on
this idea that there has to be something
above you that that is sort of real and
empirical
otherwise you'll always be looking for
it in man and that
that has sort of led to where we're at
now with so many of these movements
because they think
they can fix man and perhaps man can't
be fixed
yeah well i think in terms of my own
views i'm a christian i'm very i'm very
open about that
always have been raised in a christian
family whole family is christian
and one thing i'm noticing which i think
is interesting is a lot of people who
are
atheist or agnostic i'm finding who have
been
embroiled in some of this to a degree
not everybody but i think that a lot of
people
are one some of them are actually
starting to
[Music]
believe in god and become more religious
but even those who are not i think are
starting to
better understand some of the benefits
of religion and sort of seeing what can
take place in its absence because i do
believe i don't know how well this has
been studied i do believe that people
have
kind of what i call a religious core
so everybody it's natural as an adult as
you get older to
contemplate the meaning of life or
wonder what the ultimate power is wonder
why
wonder how we all got here why we all
are here
um want to know what the ideal is where
does morality come from all these ideas
people want to have community people
want to be a part of something and
that's to me that's just inherent in
human nature
so for some people who are religious the
religion
solves and answers a lot of a lot of
those things
whereas i think for somebody who is
not um something else
normally or often i mean i may not say
normally but
often will fill
that gap yeah well that's why that's why
pete bogosian
he talks about this post-modernism as a
secular religion
which makes so much sense and this is
he's an atheist i mean he wrote a book
called the manual
for creating atheists so that this is
not something that he wants to see
where where atheism maybe has a
an end of the road that isn't exactly
what they want it to be yeah but he
describes that as a secular religion and
i think a lot of atheists because i get
this i mean i get a lot of fan mail
about this where atheists are like
peterson often was the guy that's kind
of showed them okay
that the road kind of ends of secularism
if it's unhinged
from something real before that that
you're gonna end up in this
in this you know competing
intersectional mess
well i don't think it's an accident that
i mean even in the 20th century
i don't think it's an accident that the
big
scary totalitarian fascist regimes
made a significant effort to root
religion
out of people and out of society before
they implemented
their own structures and ideologies
because religion if you've got something
that's already in
that hole then i do personally believe
of course religion can be used for
it can be used for malice it can be
misused for evil and whatever
but i think in its i think a lot of
people have this sort of
utopian idea that if you could root that
out
then everyone would kind of get along
stop fighting over what and i truly
don't believe that i think on an
individual
basis fine you know if someone if
someone can
be moral and rational and have their own
thoughts and ideas and whatever
that is complete in absence of any
belief in god or religion or whatever
then
absolutely totally fine when you take
hundreds of millions of people or
billions of people
and you root that out i this might be
the pessimist in me
but i don't believe that i don't i don't
think
that space won't stay empty yeah
something else
better or worse will come in there
and fill that hole it could be this
weird intersectional religion
it could be some kind of very heavy
political
ideology or belief which basically turns
some sort of
leader into a god um
it could be drugs or addiction or it can
be yeah it
it could be drugs it can be because
people want to find
something else because ultimately people
think well
you know we're we're just here there's
got to be some
meaning or purpose or maybe some other
dimension i mean it's like when you get
people who say you know i'm not
religious but i'm spiritual
and you know they're searching maybe
they're using psychedelic drugs to find
to
enter some other plane or they're
meditating or whatever and then
which is which is fine but um to me it's
it's very much a
parallel it's like you're trying to
create something
new like a new or an alternative version
which has some of the ideas on some of
the principles but
misses the sort of aspect of a deity
or something super supernatural but um
yeah i i don't know i'm not here making
an argument for religion sure
i'm just more saying that well it's
interesting because you're you're in
america
i think it's a very american view that
that you're laying out there because
that's the view of the founders right
they said these are god-given rights we
didn't give you
these rights but at the same time what
did they say you have freedom of
religion
and freedom from religion yeah so it's a
really beautiful thing that these rights
came from something else before us we're
not handing them to you
and there's a there's a real freedom in
that yeah definitely and
another one i mean just on a more
pragmatic level again this is not an
argument in favor of
for religion but i do also think that
there's a danger
if a whole society loses that
and another one does not
i think that that opens them up for
a potential takeover and the lack of a
better sense right i think if you've got
if you can have hundreds of millions of
people who are united around
this idea or belief system and then
you've got people who are kind of
splintered off and siloed and isolated
and they don't have anything
that's really they feel any way is
uniting them as a community or what not
i do think that
poses as a threat to them because
there's no
there's there's nothing competing to
protect against that so i think
on again on a wider longer term span i
do think that's something that's a
potential risk some people might say
okay well whatever that doesn't matter
but
those are my personal that's my personal
thought on it is something i've thought
about
is something i've thought about quite a
lot um and again you know having grown
up in
a country like saudi arabia which is
99.99
um islamic and everybody essentially
believes in god and everybody follows
the same religion and
they've got very strict rules on
making sure things stay that way right
there's zero churches there
zero synagogues you can only build
mosques um
and so and you know they're they're very
strict and structured in the way that
they
they do certain things some people might
not like that but again
from their own perspective if i use
empathy to kind of put myself in their
shoes it's like okay i get what i can
get
what you're doing here and why you may
be doing this so even if people in the
western world don't like it or they may
think that
it's backwards or that it's it's not
correct and whatnot
you can understand i think if you've got
high degree of empathy
you can understand where some of that
thinking
sort of comes from yeah yeah so you're
saying that perhaps
having a little bit of the traditional
sense and also a little bit of free
thinking might be
yeah the way to do it yeah i think
pretty crazy man i think you can reach
out you can reach a happy happy medium
you know um
you're always going to have a balance
between liberty
and on the other side
let's see if you give people absolute
liberty and freedom
then that has consequences
um i say this from someone who's pretty
libertarian it generally thinks people
should be able to
do what they want as long as it's not
harming killing or taking from
other people but you need some
if you want that to function you need
some kind of fabric
over it so that people do behave
in a way that's not massively
destructive to
themselves or to others
and then you've got the opposite where
you've got a country
like the one i one i grew up in where
it's super super duper strict
you know in some things there's plenty
of things that i think are way too
strict and which i
personally don't believe in or
subscribe to um but
stuff is very ordered and
everyone knows how things kind of work
and
there are problems that you get in the
west that you don't
really get there or to far lesser
degrees just because people are
you know things things are so much more
stringent and structured and
repercussions for certain things are way
more serious i mean for example
the death penalty for dealing drugs um
which i can totally understand someone
thinking that's that's way too hardcore
but you know you look at some of the
problems some of the biggest problems in
the
us and the uk are drug-related or
alcohol related i think there's a happy
medium here
i think yeah exactly this is what i
always say to people that might be an
unhappy media yeah
that's what i always say i think there's
a happy medium i don't think you need to
go all the way that way
but if you're going to go all the way
that way in terms of legality you need
something that
it's like okay maybe people should be
allowed to do some of these things they
shouldn't necessarily have a law saying
you can't do that you can't do that you
can't do that
punishment punishment punishment but
you also want people to i don't know
like
this this is again is what i think like
religion
has done in the past and still still
continues to so it's like okay it's not
illegal
to do all of these things you're not
going to get punished but people know
okay well i'm going to behave in this
certain way because that's what
pleases god and my family and wider
society and whatnot if i
don't do these things and what not so i
don't know i don't have all the answers
yeah
you don't have all the answers i guess
forget some of these other questions
uh my last question because you are a
brit legally i have to ask you
uh what's gonna happen with brexit oh
gosh i don't know but they need to just
make it
happen really um i take i take an
unpopular view on this in that i've
never believed the dooms
the doomsday predictions on either side
i'm not a believer that if the uk were
to stay in the eu
that it would everything would go
horribly wrong i'm also not of the
opinion that if the uk leaves the eu
things will go horribly wrong i think
the uk
in the long term britain will be fine
either way
now that i think that the vote has
happened and majority of people voted to
leave
i think that that needs to be honored i
think that
that needs to happen i don't know all
the details of the best way to
formulate a deal or to just pull out
with no deal or anything like that
but i think that now people have voted
um
it's important that that is upheld
i don't really like this idea that of
there being
a vote a democratic vote and then
people start contesting because and they
don't like the
they don't like the result yeah well it
just strikes me as a as a
true uh firewall for the rest of the
west like can
a free western democracy have a vote and
then the powers that be just decide not
to allow that vote yeah so if it doesn't
happen regardless of whether you want it
to happen or not
the people voted away a certain way and
what would you be signaling to all of
the other western leaders who would love
to start ignoring
what the people say you'd be signaling
ah they got away with it in england of
all places so what's next so yeah
i think i think they need to honor it
and just i'm bored of it
yeah i'll honestly honestly i'm on board
people ask me what do you think of
breaks i'm like i'm bored just make it
just get it done i don't know
all the processes but that's what that's
what those that's what your jobs are
that's why you were
that's what you were voted for so well
you bounce around enough so if it gets
really if it gets really wacky over
there
we could use you here okay that'll be
just fine you can join us
in our racist patriarchy i have a
feeling we're gonna do this again my
friend awesome man all right
it was a pleasure and for more on zooby
you can follow him
on twitter at zooby music if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell